-You used your show on Monday
to address specifically
Bill O´Reilly, who had,
basically, made the point
that no women,
in all his years,
had ever gone to anyone in
charge at Fox News
and said
that his behavior was bad.
You gave an impassioned speech,
which I thought was wonderful,
and I´m glad you did it,
where you pointed out
that you had gone to Fox News
and pointed that out
and no one had done anything.
-Mm-hmm.
-Did you know right away
that you were gonna do that,
as soon as you heard him say
his falsehood about the fact,
that no one had ever done it?
-It was more of the combo,
honestly, Seth.
It was the combo of him
saying that
and the news that he had paid
$32 million to settle a claim.
-That seems like a lot, right?
-That´s not nuisance value.
-Yeah.
-I mean, that´s --
I get --
Litigations happen all the time.
A lot of them are nonsense,
and you pay some small amount
to make them go away.
$32 million
is a different story.
And he was renewed at the
company after he did that.
And I know that Fox
says it didn´t know.
The question remains,
"Why didn´t they?"
Why wouldn´t you know?
Why wouldn´t you ask
before you bring this man
back in the workplace and
unleash him on the workforce?
And so the combination
of those things, I just --
and what´s happening
in the country, it was time.
It was time to tell that story.
I take no pleasure in, you know,
discussing Fox News in that way
because I had
a lot of good years there,
and they´re not all bad.
They´ve got some great people.
He is not one of them.
-Yeah.
You --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also thought...
This was very interesting to me,
because I think
one of the things that
makes it so difficult for women
to report this
about anyone,
be it Harvey Weinstein,
be it Bill O´Reilly,
is they´re immediately attacked.
And one of the ways
they´re attacked is,
"Oh, why would you
have ever been on their show?"
or "Why would you have ever
posed with this photo
where you´re smiling?"
One of the things
Bill O´Reilly did is
he pointed out
and basically said,
"You can read them
on my website,"
that you and Gretchen Carlson,
who had accused Roger Ailes
of this same sort of thing,
had written him thank-you notes.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you think that speaks
to exactly how hard it is
for women to report
this sort of thing?
Like, something that small
can be used
to basically
impugn your character?
-I mean, I think it´s right out
of the playbook
of a lot of these guys.
I mean, ask yourselves,
"Who keeps thank-you notes
from nine years earlier
and puts them in a file
just in case they need them,
right?"
-Yeah --
-I mean --
-They might be that
he´s only ever gotten the two.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Anyway, everybody knows
you can have a decent working
relationship with somebody,
as I did with him for years,
and then you get new information
about said person
that changes your view.
-Yeah.
So, what do you --
In general, like, not just --
In any place, in any workplace,
how important do you think
it sort of means
to report this thing,
this kind of thing is,
and what would you suggest
for a workplace
to make sure it´s a place where
it´s safe for women
to say this sort of thing
is going on?
-It´s a great question,
and I have said publicly
that I hate when people
ask these victims
when they come forward --
A better word is accusers,
because we don´t know for sure
whether anybody´s,
in fact, a victim.
"Did you report it?
Did you report it?"
Or, "Why didn´t you report it?"
And the first question
you need to ask is,
"Was there
a safe avenue for reporting?"
And only if the answer
to that question is yes
do you get to ask
that next question.
-Mm-hmm.
-Because let me tell you,
the answer to that question was
no at my workplace for years.
There wasn´t.
HR was controlled by the CEO,
who was harassing half of
the women in the building.
And so it was not
a meaningful outlet.
And even if it had been,
I´ve spoken to so many women
about this.
They´re afraid.
Even if HR is a real option,
it doesn´t always go your way.
And if you don´t
win this contest,
you know, if you take a shot at
the King, you better kill him,
you´ve heard that saying?
-Mm-hmm.
-If you don´t win this,
you know, showdown,
you know
what´s gonna happen to you,
and it doesn´t always --
it´s not always obvious.
Maybe the next contract
you´re not quite as impressive
as you used to be,
and you can´t prove
that it was the fact
that you raised this complaint.
So, my feeling is,
it´s fine for the record.
We need to say, "Report.
Go report it. Report it."
But I also feel like,
"Easy for me and you to say.
We´ve got these great jobs,
and we´ll be fine
if we get fired."
But the reality is,
"A," women --
It can happen to men, too --
need to form an underground army
where they talk to each other
and know they´re not alone.
And, "B,"
men in positions of power --
and women --
we need more of those.
But men in positions of power
need to not only
stick up for us publicly
but in the bars and at nighttime
and when we´re not there
and when they´re talking about
us in this way
and when we´re walking out
and they´re looking at our ass.
Those are the moments you need
to stand up and say, "Dude, no."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
Well, I´m really happy
you´re in the building,
and I am very happy when
you talk about things like that,
but I also like watching you
make scones with Anthony Weiner.
When is that?
[ Laughter ]
Is that next Monday?
-I don´t think
they allow those visits.
-Yeah, I don´t think so, either.
-I hope.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.